good morning it's tuesday probably my
favorite book about writing is annie
dillard's the writing life which
contains the brilliant observation how
we spend our days is of course how we
spend our lives it's a reminder to me
that while they tend to separate the
ideas of a day's work and a wife's work
they aren't really separable because
lives are made out of days like today i
will attend several meetings and get a
haircut and call a plumber none of which
feels like my life's work but it is
because how we spend our days is how we
spend our lives which means of course
that i should be very careful how i
spend my days but in trying to be
careful i quickly run up against a huge
obstacle which is that while
aspirational capitalism may tell me that
i have absolute choice in how i spend my
life the truth is i don't like i have
been immensely privileged in my
professional life but even so i don't
have that much choice in what i do with
my days like tomorrow for example i
cannot go to space because i have an
inner ear disorder and also i'm not a
billionaire and i cannot spend tomorrow
caring for the sick in hospitals because
i lack the training and expertise to be
a nurse and so on in fact i can't do
almost everything tomorrow right and the
constraints of our lived reality are not
generally our fault even if our social
and economic structures would sometimes
tell us that they are and so in
considering that how we spend our days
is how we spend our lives we must
remember that we often have fairly
limited choice in how we spend our days
most of us however have at least some
choice like i do not have to get a
haircut today i could instead do
something fun and memorable with my day
like drive to the world's largest ball
of paint or call a friend from
elementary school but the thing is i
would like my hair to look a little
less and so i kind of need to get a
haircut and i kind of need to go to
those meetings because people are
counting on me to be there so that's
what i'm gonna do with my day and in
turn what i'm gonna do with a lot of my
life semi-related and i promise we'll
get back to the annie dillard stuff but
sometimes i think about the actor george
raft who once said of losing his 10
million dollar fortune part of the loot
went for gambling part for horses and
part for women the rest i spent
foolishly it's a dumb joke but it
contains within it something that is
useful to me which is that a lot of
times the work that people see as
productive uses of my life is not what i
actually experience to be productive
uses of my life like to modify that joke
to myself i spend most of my hours idly
daydreaming or driving my children to
and from school the rest of my time i
squander because like when i think about
capital p productivity i often find that
what is economically or even socially
productive is not what is deeply
personally productive like yesterday the
most economically productive part of my
day was making a podcast that a lot of
people listen to and writing a little
bit of a book that hopefully some people
will read someday but actually the most
productive part of my day was the hour i
spent driving my kid home from school
and running errands and talking about
this and that because as the great
philosopher hank green put it you will
always struggle with not feeling
productive until you accept that your
own joy can be something you produce my
mattering as a person is not contingent
upon my production especially not my
production that the world recognizes as
productivity in fact for me sometimes
the most important work is in merely
thinking or merely being especially
being present for those i love in short
when i expand my definition of
productivity to include how i want to
spend my life i find that i feel better
about how i spend my days so hank i'm
off now for the most productive part of
my day attending some meetings getting a
haircut and picking up my children from
school i will see you on friday